Go ahead and update the save profile method
in conference API to save the profile entity in
the data store. You can look for the place
marked TODO 3 in the save profile method and
that's where you add the code to save the
entity. When you've added the code, go ahead and
run your app on localhost and then go to
the API's explorer and execute the save profile method.
Use the API's explorer to try out the updated
save profile function. You'll see the responses you did
before but you'll need to go to the admin
console to check that the profile entity was saved
in the data store. And just a reminder, to
get to the admin console on localhost, you go
to localhost colon port number like localhost colon ADAT
and then you type underscore Slash ADMIN. What properties
does your profile entity show in the admin console? Check each one that applies.